زلزال تركيا وصلت كمان الى كمبوديا ومو
المقصود هنا هزات ارتداديه او شيء من هذا
النوع بل المقصود ممكن نسميه توتر سياسي
او اعلامي فرئيس وزراء كمبودي امر باغلاق
محطه اذاعيه اسمها فويس اوف ديمقراصي او
صوت الديمقراطيه واتهمهم بالافتراء على
ابنه اللي هو بالمناسبه كمان
مرشحه عشان يخلف والده لما يتنحى وانتشرت
صوت او انتشرت كمان صور كمان من اغلاق
المحطه الاذاعيه اللي لها كمان موقع
اخباري وصور للموظفين وهم جالسين بيبكوا
في المقر
كلكم بتسالوا الان اكيد ايش علاقه الزلزال
تركيا في الموضوع هذا العلاقه هي ان
الاذاعه نقلت خبر انه رئيس الجيش اللي هو
ابن رئيس الحكومه وقع نيابه عن والده
وثيقه تسمح بالتبرع ب 100 الف دولار
للمساعده في الاغاثه من الزلزال لكن رئيس
الوزراء الكمبودي طلع وقال كذب وما حصل
وهو الوحيد كرئيس الوزراء عنده السلطه
للتوقيع على وثيقه من هذا النوع ومع انه
الاذاعه والموقع طلعوا اعترفوا انه
ارتكبوا خطا لكن هذا ما ارض رئيس الحكومه
لمعروف بقبضه الحديديه في الحكم من 38 سنه
وبالمناسبه هذه الاذاعه كانت واحده يعني
من اخر وسائل الاعلام الحره يعني في
البلاد